So 3.14, is greater than this z critical value for an alpha level of 0.001. So,
a z score of 3.14 occurs out here somewhere in the green region. So this is
significant at probability less than 0.001. And 2.07 is between 1.65 and 2.32.
So that z score, occurs somewhere in this red region. So it's significant at p
less than .05. Hopefully this is making sense. Let's do that last two. 2.57
will occur somewhere in this blue region, because that z score is in between
2.32 and 3.08. So the probability of getting this z score is 0.01. And finally,
this is a really huge z score so, this sample mean occurs somewhere way out
here, far from the mean. But we don't conventionally have an alpha level that
is that small, so we'll just say that the probability of getting that sample
mean, is less than 0.001, good job. So just to recap, if our sample mean falls
in the critical region, for an alpha level of 0.05, It's unlikely and therefore
probably didn't occur by chance. Something's going on, and there are different
levels that help us decide how sure we are.